- [Presenter] This is
a tiny home on Airbnb.
So far this year,
this listing has brought in
over $20,000 for its host.
The typical U.S. host in 2021
earned over $13,800
according to the company.
- The tiny home doesn't
cost a lot to build,
and yet it could charge
hundreds of dollars a night.
- [Presenter] Airbnb posted a
profit in its second quarter,
as guests booked a record
number of stays and experiences
and hosts increased prices for
rentals amid high inflation,
but people didn't book as much
as analysts had projected,
and the company's summer bookings forecast
fell short of expectations.
- Obviously it's an incredibly
dynamic period of time,
but I'm still expecting
an incredibly strong period of travel
even if people pull back spending some.
- [Presenter] So how did the largest
home sharing platform in the U.S.
navigate its biggest crises?
And could it borrow those lessons
to weather fears of a recession?
This is The Economics of Airbnb.
- Airbnb started
around the time of the
2008 financial crisis.
This was a time when
people were really hard hit
by the recession,
and they were looking for a
way to make an extra buck.
- [Presenter] In 2016,
the company launched Airbnb Experiences,
which let travelers book
classes, tours, and outings.
Airbnb also spent more as it grew.
- The CEO branched out
into all kinds of things
like he wanted to have a media studios,
he wanted to branch into transportation.
- [Presenter] And then the pandemic hit.
Business was down 80%
forcing Airbnb to take on
$2,000,000,000 in debt,
and pause all non-essential projects.
- I hope I never do a side
project again in my life.
I learned a lesson,
and I think the lesson is
when you try to do new
things as side things,
they don't work.
- [Presenter] Summer of 2020
was a turning point for Airbnb.
- [Rana] People started
quarantining with their families.
Friends started taking staycations
while they could work remote.
So that's something that
definitely benefited Airbnb.
- [Presenter] Local travel
became its stronghold,
and people started using the
platform for longer stays.
The company was one of the
hottest public listings of 2020,
though with stock price
has fallen since then
amid a broad market cool off.
In August, Airbnb projected
record third quarter revenue
on the back of higher rental prices,
and said it expects to post
its first full year profit
this year.
- A lot of businesses have lucky moments,
but there's something to
be said about getting lucky
and also being able to ride
that wave and capitalize on it.
- [Presenter] That's what Airbnb says
it has done from the start.
- Back then in 2008, a lot
of people turned to hosting,
because they were losing their homes,
high housing prices,
and a lot of people because
they didn't have as much money
were looking for more
affordable ways to travel
than ever before.
- [Rana] That really helped them
bring a lot of people who were looking for
ways to make up for lost
income onto the platform.
And you can really see
them capitalize on timing
during the pandemic as well.
- [Presenter] Airbnb
redesigned its app and website
to focus on local stays
during the pandemic.
Last summer, it launched
a flexible search feature,
which curates trips for people
who don't know where they want to go.
- [Rana] The pandemic and remote work
gave us that flexibility.
You know, we could travel during the week
and still work remote.
So Airbnb starts noticing
this trend and it says,
oh my God we can,
you know, we can sort of
capitalize on this, and they do.
- [Presenter] In May,
Airbnb launched another
redesign of its search tool
that split homes into
more than 50 categories
as a way to steer people to places
they wouldn't otherwise have picked.
- [Rana] So what they're trying to do is
they're trying to fill existing homes
instead of adding more and more homes.
- [Presenter] Some analysts say
this is key to the company's future growth
since global occupancy rates are low.
When it comes to addressing
safety issues on its platform,
some cities have complained that
Airbnb has been too hands off.
- They're not actively
monitoring these properties
because frankly they
can't, they don't own them.
So that's really where a lot
of their problems stem from.
- Four people killed, another four hurt,
all of it happening in a
house rented out on Airbnb.
- [Presenter] After a
2019 Halloween shooting,
the company announced safety measures
including a 24/7 neighborhood
hotline to field complaints.
- [Brian] We've banned all
parties globally on Airbnb.
We have a risky reservation queue
where we looking at any
suspicious activity,
and we have a pretty
hands-on team that's using
some pretty advanced like
machine learning technology
to essentially identify
anything we think is suspicious.
If it is, we'll continue
to seek more information.
- [Presenter] The company says
the number of party complaints
have dropped 44% in the last two years.
Airbnb has also been trying
to reduce that rate further
by doing things like blocking
one or two nights stays
on new year's Eve and Halloween
for guests without a
history of positive reviews,
but incidents keep happening.
- [Rana] Earlier this year,
we had a shooting in Pittsburgh,
and again, you know, people were injured.
- [Presenter] City officials
have also blamed Airbnb
for ruining the long term rental market
in some small communities
- What's happened is a lot of people
are just snapping up
properties and renting them.
And as a result,
locals don't have enough
properties to rent long term.
Airbnb doesn't think that it's actually
affected the long term rental market,
but you know if you ask city officials,
they have a different story.
- [Presenter] For example, in 2020,
the Mayor of Sedona,
Arizona, a tourist hotspot,
said that the demand for Airbnb rentals
worsened the shortage
of affordable housing
and demolished the long
term rental market.
- If we are, you know,
part of the problem,
we are gonna work with cities.
That's why we've done numerous
agreements with cities
to create restrictions.
We actually do want Airbnb
to get more and more
into long term housing.
We want people to really feel
invested in the community.
- [Rana] One of the things
that Airbnb is doing now
is it's trying to direct people
to areas where it has supply,
and that sort of also takes
the load off of certain places
that everyone might go to
and that might get sort of overburdened
- [Presenter] In April,
Airbnb announced
that its employees can
work from almost anywhere
without a pay cut.
- So if more businesses
do follow Airbnb's lead,
Airbnb stands to gain in
its home rental business
because that would mean,
more digital nomads,
more people traveling, and
likely booking more Airbnbs.
- [Presenter] But some
travelers are concerned
about rising nightly rates,
and some analysts believe that
hotel chains and competitors
like Expedia Group,
stand to gain as business
travel picks up this year.
So the question is, can
Airbnb keep up the momentum?
- We're an incredibly lean company.
We've already been preparing for a storm
that we thought was
inevitable for years to come.
- [Presenter] Airbnb
dramatically cut costs
during the pandemic,
and analysts have credited the company
for keeping those down
even as travel rebounded.
While a potential economic
downturn could decrease demand,
Airbnb says it could also bring
more hosts to the platform.
- As the economy is gonna be slowing down,
I think more and more people
are gonna be interested in saving money,
and I think they're
also gonna be interested
in new ways to make money.
- [Presenter] And unlike
hotels with fixed properties,
Airbnb can adapt quickly
by spotlighting properties
that serve travelers changing needs,
like it did during the
switch to local travel.
- I think even as we're
entering a recession,
people have been kind
of isolated for years
and they're yearning to get out.
And the one thing
I think you're gonna
see them spend money on,
is they're gonna continue to travel.
(upbeat music)